it's a chance for children to get
hands-on experience with technology
an old skoda assembly hall for trains
and trams in pilsen has been converted
into a science center for children
the european union supports the center
with a 12 million euro subsidy
trams are still assembled here in new
halls nearby
the czech republic's eu membership has
been a major boon for skoda
transportation
in just five years revenues have
increased by 35 percent to around 700
million euros
we can participate without any
restriction within all european union
countries in in all public tenders which
is very important for us there are no
restrictions at the moment
secondly we are participating in the
tenders which are being financed from
the european union funds i would say
as many countries entered in the eu like
for example hungary i would say the same
as czech republic there's a lot of
operational programs
because eu is specially focusing
in our segment on supporting the public
transport
without the eu's support the company
would not be getting nearly as many
orders that helps to secure the jobs of
skoda's 4000 employees
i've been working for the company for 40
years now
there's an immense difference between
what it was like before eu membership
and after
it's far more pleasant to work here and
we've also got a new plant
but the vice president says many eu
norms have yet to be implemented for the
certification of locomotives for example
we still have a lot of local special
norms which we have to fulfill
therefore it makes us
i would say some complications
or wrinkles on our faces
that we have to additional fulfill some
national norms for a country germany
australia czech republic each country
has still some nation norms and this is
one of the biggest
pains which we are wishing
in the future will will change
in pilsen's industrial district czech
and british business people hold a get
together the czechs hope to break into
the british market with their laser
technology and machine components
it's ava brechova's job to arrange
contacts like this she welcomes every
new investor
you could see in the industrial zone
it's uh
is the
icing and the best industrial zones in
czech republic during the last 20 years
it's still we have the certificate for
it
but now it's full
yeah it's better to be
part of the of the eu not only as a
paraplegic republic
because it's it's better if you if you
come somewhere and tell okay i'm from
czech republic it's it's in eu it's in
europe
pilsen's old town has been thoroughly
restored also with eu support in
preparation for the city's upcoming year
as european capital of culture
how has eu membership affected the lives
of the people who live here
the freedom of movement is better that's
what i think is good
and the chances to work abroad
just to work in czech republic
at the skoda test track 31 new trams are
being handed over to buyers from the
city of mishkoltz in hungary
but shkoda's customers are by no means
only from eastern europe
i think the feedback we are getting now
from the market for example from germany
when we have been awarded with a
contract from uh one of the major um
railway operator in the world from db
is showing that
we don't we don't have to feel somehow
smaller or weaker compared to the to the
big competitors
a 110 million euro contract has just
come in from deutsche bahn
starting in 2016 the munich nuremberg
trains will be made by skoda